all right guys bang bang I'm here with
Will Will let's just jump right into it
reflexivity research they published a Q2
report somewhere like a public market
report for public company but for the
Bitcoin network uh the first chart that
you guys have is the price drawdown
since all-time high what's this showing
us yeah for sure so essentially what
you're looking at is just in red the
further down that the red line goes uh
the more prices draw down from its prior
all-time high and so as you can see uh
Bitcoin Drew down as much as 75 towards
the back half of last year but it's now
down on a relative basis only uh 55 from
its all-time high uh Bitcoins had a
massive year thus far up 85 percent
relative to Gold being up five percent
and even over double the performance of
the NASDAQ which has been on a record
run this year uh which is up about 40
year-to-date as well so the next one
that you have is the price performance
since the cycle low what is that showing
us yeah so we included a couple charts
to just look at uh kind of the current
cycle relative to previous Market cycles
for BTC uh we have two charts that I
guess we can you know switch back and
forth with and show so the first is
bitcoin's price performance from its
prior cycle lows on the second is
bitcoin's price performance since its
prior cycle high and so what this is
showing is essentially while history
doesn't always repeat it often Rhymes
and we can see that this current cycle
is mirroring uh similar to price action
to uh the you know couple other cycles
that are shown here color coded on the
charts and when we see past Cycles
obviously the kind of 2010 to 2013 cycle
that was like kind of the most explosive
one should we expect to have less and
less explosiveness to these moves over
time as the holder base gets larger and
more Diversified yeah I think it's a
pretty fair assumption to make that
you'll likely see diminishing returns
um from like a cycle to cycle basis as
the market continues to mature and
becomes a larger asset class because you
just need more Capital to be able to
move it you know in that order of
magnitude of price growth now let's talk
about bitcoin's market cap dominance
we've seen that it dropped significantly
during the bull market but it has come
roaring back sitting now I think over 50
percent why is that such an important
metric yeah so we kind of structured off
this one part of the report and
essentially looking at Market structure
and the first thing that we mentioned is
is what you just described which is this
Bitcoin market cap dominance charts
you're essentially looking at bitcoin's
market capitalization relative to uh the
market capitalization of all the other
crypto Assets in the market and what we
can see is that Bitcoins market
dominance is now over 51 percent uh this
is the highest that it's been
um since uh I think April of 2021 uh so
you know over two years now
um of of Bitcoin dominance that we've
seen kind of reclaimed over these last
couple weeks and I think a big part of
that has been we've had two kind of
idiosyncratic uh news events that have
benefited Bitcoin at least on a relative
basis to the other two crypto uh
relative to the other crypto assets uh
the first one is the svb uh kind of you
know collapse and income banking crisis
that we saw in March of uh earlier this
year and then the second one uh is this
BlackRock ETF filing and other ETF
filings that we've seen following the
BlackRock run and so that's you uniquely
benefited Bitcoin relative to the other
crypto assets and so I think that's
driven a lot of flows into BTC relative
to those other assets so I think that's
like an opinion you have but you also
can then go look at the Perpetual
volumes and and it seems that there's a
Divergence there between Bitcoin and
ethereum as well yeah so when we look at
uh what's here on the screen which is
essentially just looking at the uh
Bitcoin Perpetual swap uh volume which
is uh the most liquid product that's
traded in crypto on a relative basis to
ethereum's Perpetual uh Futures volume
we can see that there's been this
Divergence as you described over kind of
the last month or two especially after
the BlackRock filing and what that means
is that there's more kind of speculative
interest and people looking to kind of
wage your bets on bitcoin relative uh to
ethereum now when we go and we look at
different markets around the world one
of the things that you've taught me that
I find just absolutely fascinating is in
recent weeks the US has had a premium in
trading hours compared to all other
markets explain this a little bit more
yeah so I think you know even outside of
that we can see that the ETF trade has
been kind of in full effect across 7
several different things but who's been
primarily putting that trade on it
appears that it is us-based entities
that you just alluded to there's two
things that I kind of look at as
evidence of that the first is What's
called the cumulative return by session
that we can look at from Velo data here
on the screen uh we have it broken down
into the EU APAC and then U.S trading
sessions and so what we can see is that
especially again since the BlackRock
filing but even slightly beforehand we
could see that the US has been more
actively bidding BTC relative to those
other trading sessions and then as
another piece of evidence that we can
look at to see that there's kind of
us-based firms getting involved in BTC
recently we can look at the coinbase
exchange trading volume the coinbase
price premium relative to the other
exchanges this means that Bitcoin has
been trading marginally higher on
coinbase relative to the other crypto
venues and then the last piece of
evidence as well is looking at CME
Futures open interest so this looks at
the total number of Futures contracts
outstanding on the CME who usually
trades on the CME it's not kind of
crypto degenerates uh that are looking
to punt on Leverage it's kind of
us-based traditional type firms and we
can see a clear jump in CME Futures open
interest following the BlackRock ETF
about a billion dollars of open interest
was added in that time period Speaking
of ETFs I think that now we're starting
to see grayscales uh kind of discount to
nav Titan a little bit and so it's
getting a little bit more attractive for
investors but obviously still a pretty
big deep discount how do you read into
that yeah so I think again this is
evidence of kind of the ETF trade being
put on
um as you mentioned we're looking at
here in the chart on the top portion is
just the G the price of gbtc on the
bottom we're looking at the Discounter
premium uh to nav so or net asset value
so how closely essentially is the trust
tracking the underlying Bitcoin that
it's supposed to be giving investors
exposure to and what we can see is that
that discount has come down from roughly
uh 50 uh down to about 30 percent so
this is the kind of lowest that the
discount has been in over a year what
does that indicate it shows that uh it's
more closely Contracting that underlying
net asset value of the price of Bitcoin
and I believe that it's the market
starting to price in the idea that there
could potentially be a bunch of ETFs
approved including uh gray skills as
they are actively you know undergoing a
lawsuit against the SEC to get their ETF
approved that makes sense now one of the
things that you have here is uh looking
at the liquidity in bitcoin's market and
you specifically look at coin
denominated kind of bids and asks in the
order books this is getting a little bit
more technical so explain a little bit
kind of how this works and then why is
it so muted in your opinion yeah sure so
I think we should maybe start with like
why is liquidity important in markets
liquidity is important because it gives
the ability for large buyers and sellers
to transact within a market and even get
involved so you know you could have
someone that was maybe interested in uh
purchasing Bitcoin that managed a
multi-billion dollar hedge fund when it
was a million dollar market cap but they
just couldn't remotely get any amount of
size that's relevant to them
um and so therefore they had to wait
until the market became more liquid so
there's a very kind of tight correlation
with the ability for institutions to get
active in the market and and the amount
of liquidity that's in the market and so
what we can see here on the chart as you
described is the coin denominated uh to
what we have this we have what we have
showing is the two percent Market depth
so essentially uh what's the amount of
BTC uh in the order book between the
current trading price and what would
move the price up and down two percent
essentially as a proxy for how much
liquidity there is in the Bitcoin Market
we can see that that's continued to
decline over the last year uh despite
the positive price appreciation that
we've seen throughout the year
um and that's a reflection of a the kind
of counterparty risk that we've seen
throughout the entire crypto space with
all the different exchanges and
different venues and lenders blowing up
throughout the entire space as well as
market makers and then also Sonic you
know kind of the regulatory uncertainty
that we've seen in crypto that's kind of
plagued at least you know us-based
crypto firms and provided a ton of you
know regulatory uncertainty for those
firms over the last year or so uh and so
what does this all mean
it just means that larger buys and sells
are going to have a larger impact on the
market overall and we're likely to see
more volatility as a byproduct of that
because there's more price impact on
those large buys or cells in the market
so let's talk about kind of the network
uh usage itself obviously the big story
in Q2 was ordinals and inscriptions it
just exploded in terms of popularity
what do you see there yeah so you know
it's kind of funny like it doesn't even
feel like that was last quarter with all
the regulatory stuff that took place and
then all the ETF news towards the back
half of the quarter but ordinals really
blew up the beginning of April they
passed 10 million inscriptions in in
early April uh reached as high as 14.7
million now and also now they've
generated a whopping 56 million dollars
in fees for the network uh which is a
you know very relevant amount uh you
know it's not a trivial amount trivial
amount for the network so it's a very
positive thing for miners of course
because it's bringing them in more
Revenue but we have since seen that kind
of of course the cumulative value
continue to rise but the number of deal
inscriptions has continued to drop off
and then as a byproduct of this we've
seen transaction fees come down so
amidst all the interest around ordinals
we saw an explosion of transaction fees
reached the highest level that they had
been since early 2021 during kind of you
know the speculative Mania of the peak
of the bull market in in early 2021 but
since we've seen transaction fees revert
back down to essentially the levels that
they were before kind of the big uh you
know speculative Mania around ordinals
in April and so when you see these
transaction fees that big spike and then
they kind of come back down is the
expectation that they should kind of
return back to that normal State and
stay quite low especially with things
like lightning Network Etc taking a lot
of the the pressure off so even if we
enter into another bull market fees
shouldn't really Spike uh as they had
maybe the 2017 bull market yeah I mean
to your point I think ordinals were you
know a kind of good wake-up call for a
lot of people and that Bitcoin could use
some type of layer two scaling solution
maybe it's lightning maybe it's
something else that doesn't even exist
yet but you know if we see that type of
behavior return where the men pulls
super backed up uh costs a ton to get
people to be able to transact on the
network you know it could be beneficial
to have some type of scaling solution
like a L2 that we could move a lot of
that kind of you know smaller
transactional activity too so that
people are able to transact without
having to pay a ton of fees now let's
talk about the number of Bitcoin wallet
addresses on chain with at least one
Bitcoin we now cross over a million I
believe yeah this is kind of a just fun
stat that I decided to throw in uh if we
look at the number of addresses that
have at least one Bitcoin uh this
quarter or last quarter that crossed uh
1 million so there's now one million
whole Corners uh on the Bitcoin Network
what is this Illustrated illustrates uh
that you know larger uh Market
participants are losing market share to
the smaller guys that continue to
accumulate when we look at the amount of
BTC held by uh on-chain entities with
less than 10 BTC relative to overall
circulating Supply we can also see that
they're continuing to take up a larger
portion of Supply therefore Bitcoin
supply distribution is continuing to
prove improve over time now one of the
things that people always talk about is
you know Bitcoin isn't scalable look at
how much Visa or Mastercard can settle
in Q2 bitcoin's Network settled two
trillion dollars of transaction volume
that's a big number that's a eight
trillion dollar uh kind of annualized
number and we're doing that in a bear
Market that's pretty impressive yeah
absolutely it's insane and when we look
at that from kind of a cumulative
perspective Bitcoins now settled 858
million transactions uh for total
cumulative value of 109 trillion dollars
so you know for a decentralized network
that's completely uncoordinated
um you know in 14 years it's a pretty
remarkable feat talk about hash rate
that just seems to grow up and to the
right and it never stops like what is
going on there yeah you know I've been
posting almost every week uh Bitcoin
hash rate all-time high and then I ended
up just feeling I was being redundant by
continuing to post the same chart every
single week oh which was a good problem
to be having because it's showing that
the Bitcoin network is continuing to
become uh more and more secure it's a
reflection of two things a uh
individuals that are already mining
purchasing more efficient machines uh
they're able to generate more hash rate
for Less energy and then second more
miners that are continuing to you know
find interest and maybe have you know
cheap access to power or whatever it may
be uh that you know have have an
economic benefit to begin mining so
let's talk about the market structure
now uh bitcoin's free flow which is the
amount of Bitcoin that is not held by
the long-term holders uh seems to be
near an all-time low is that a positive
thing yeah so essentially what we're
looking at here is uh bitcoin's
long-term holder Supply or the amount of
Supply held by long-term holders uh the
way we're defining that is by looking at
uh on-chain entities that had have held
their coins for at least 155 days if you
divide divide that by 30 you get about
five months and so the reason why this
kind of threshold was chosen is not just
some arbitrary number a glass node
basically ran some statistical studies
and found that past that five month
threshold the likelihood of coins being
spent back out of wallets drops off
dramatically and so when we look at the
percentage of long-term holders Supply
that makes up of Market uh of the
overall circulating Supply we can look
at the inverse of that so the amount of
Supply that isn't held by long-term
holders and we have what's here on the
on the screen and so in purple it's
showing you the amount of Supply that's
not held by long-term holders and so
therefore we can see that that's nearing
all-time lows as the inverse of that
which is the amount of Supply held by
long-term holders is nearing all-time
highs and so what does this mean it
means that the amount of Bitcoin that
are for sale right now is near an
all-time low and so of course that will
change as you know we get higher prices
higher prices incentivize new sellers
into the market uh but you know I think
it's pretty safe to say that the amount
of Supply that's been held over the last
two years you know throughout all the
kind of craziness in the crypto space it
doesn't appear that these entities that
are holding these coins are going to be
selling and you know anytime soon
without significantly higher prices
let's talk about realized cap uh both in
terms of just the aggregate number but
also the 90-day change you included in
the report what what is uh that realized
cab was created by Nick Carter back in
2018 and essentially looks at uh the
market capitalization of Bitcoin uh but
based on the price that coins were last
moved as opposed to just basically
taking the current marginal trading
price and multiplying it by circulating
Supply and so what realize cap serves as
is essentially looking at the aggregate
amount of value that's stored in the
network so when realized cap is
increasing it's showing you that there's
Capital inflows when realize cap is
decreasing and showing that there's
capital outflows and when we're looking
at this 90-day change we can get a more
granular view of that we can see that
over the last quarter we've added
roughly 14 billion dollars to market
caps of 13.7 billion dollars to market
cap which is showing you that we have
started to see Capital inflows again for
the first time since kind of early 2021
into the into the Bitcoin Network and
then on the next chart that we have
we're looking at realized cap relative
to market cap so what's the aggregated
cost basis of the network relative to
kind of the current marginal trading
price with the idea that a you want to
be buying whenever the kind of current
marginal trading price is below the cost
basis of the network because everyone's
underwater by definition you want to buy
when people are capitulating or you know
Under Pressure to before Sellers and
then on the inverse of that in the bull
market you want to be buying when the
current marginal trading price has
deviated far from
uh the current trading price why is that
because people are very incentivized to
sell if they're up multiples over on on
their trade or investment and so what
we're looking at here is essentially
that ratio plotted out with kind of this
undervalued Zone shown on the bottom in
green and this kind of overvalued Zone
highlighted uh there in red to show kind
of the speculative Euphoria behavior
that we see at the peak of the bull
market we just kind of pushed out of
that zone of quote-unquote deep value
and are now kind of showing a similar uh
signature in in the data relative to
other kind of the early Innings of Prior
Bitcoin bull markets so if Bitcoin is
leaving that area of kind of deep value
if you will uh does that mean that we
now are officially bottomed we're in a
bull market and kind of kicking off that
whole process again sure I mean uh you
know it's always uh tricky like calling
bottoms for sure I kind of leave I
thought I had realm of Realm of
probabilities I would say yes with the
caveat that like of course we could
retest the lows you know something takes
place like March of 2020 uh but you know
I think at this point we've kind of
moved out of that area of deep value and
accumulation
um and you know I think just the sheer
amount of foreselling that took place at
the end of 22 I think would be pretty
difficult to replicate awesome if you
enjoyed this make sure that you go check
out reflexivity research you can just go
to reflexivityresearch.com or you can
click on the link down below also we are
helping somebody who is building a brand
new data product it's been fantastic
it's called Velo v-e-l-o you can go to
velowitlist.com sign up for the wait
list or letting a couple people off
every single day and get onto that
product see you guys next Saturday